y bañó el extremo en oro de 14 quilates.
Hay un lápiz para cada persona,
y cada lápiz tiene una historia.
El Blackwing 602 es famoso por ser el instrumento de muchos escritores,
especialmente John Steinbeck y Vladimir Nabokov.
Y luego está la compañía de lápices Dixon,
responsable por el Dixon Ticonderoga.
Es un icono;
es lo primero que se piensa si se piensa en un lápiz,
o si se piensa en la escuela.
Y el lápiz es algo en lo que, yo creo,
el usuario típico nunca se ha detenido a pensar
sobre cómo se hace o por qué se hace de tal manera
porque siempre ha sido así.
En mi opinión, no hay nada que se pueda hacer
para mejorar al lápiz.
Es perfecto.